[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand elle passe la carmenti
elle est
place000
gars flamme plus à les autres femmes
alors
[Musique]
elle est
F cher comme dit lingo et aux arènes
chaque semaine elle est la reine des
cœur
madrilè tu connais pas Mireille Mireille
Mireille Mireille qu merveille elle MEUR
en FAD lorsque mon cœur sommeille j'ai
le train de Marseille et quand je me
réveille Mireille dans mes bras àuris vu
un printemps sur le guinza yosiko march
à tout petit pas à travers d'un sonum
mon de soi l'aurait cru voir marcher du
mimosa des arbres en fleurs s'en dans la
brise et si alors elle t'avait souis tu
l'aurais trouvé si poussé si exquis tu
aurais bien vu te faire àir tu connais
pas Mireille Mireille Mireille je la
vois je péqueille elle me rendfada
lorsque mon cœur sommeille j'ai le train
de Marseille et quand je me réveille
Mireille dans mes bras
sipina sur ta route tu verrais son a
noise qui t'enoute tu verrais d'un seul
coup le mer une nuit de la perce de la
harpper cet immense œil noir là
illumine alors sous le voilon on
l'imagine on se dit devant l'œil mystè
srieux dans le fond je suis presque s
qu'el
anate tu connais pas Mireille pour
trouver l'appareille c'est pas demain la
veille ça me rendait Fada parce que pour
voir Mireille ça faisait loin Marseille
merveille des merveilles Mireille la
voilà Mireille Mireille bien vite dans
mes
[Musique]
bras